six one seven eight three zero forty
seven fifty is the number let's go to
our caller from the to10 area code two
one zero go ahead yes it's Josh from San
Antonio hey go ahead yes I was just uh I
wanted to ask you know with the whole
immigration political climate going on
yep what can we do as a country as a
society more as a country beside the
ballot box to establish inhumane
treatment of immigrants okay yeah so a
few I mean so the best thing is the
first one you mentioned which is vote
the people out that will do this stuff
that's that's got to happen right you
need to do that
November it's got to happen in November
of 2020 as well other than you voting
number two is get other people to vote
okay so voter turnout is so low in this
country that those who do vote through
voter registration drives can actually
affect the results because you only have
about a 50 percent voter turnout in
general elections presidential year and
even more pathetically low during
midterms and then you can also support
organizations that are working on this
issue and we linked to a bunch of them
earlier in the week there are lots of
organizations that are working
specifically on the child internment
camps and also continue to demand the
resignation of Kristin Nielsen who has
been one of the big complicit actors in
all this I wish that it you you know we
felt like we could do more I would say
continue flooding your elected officials
email inboxes or fax machines snail mail
right continue flooding them demanding
action and beyond that I mean those are
the four things I think of would it be
would be smart to use force to like get
a change how would you do it would be
I'm not good news for us and how would
you do it and against who I guess I'm
not I guess you know it looks like I'm
too far maybe you know go out there I
guess I don't know I'm not advocating
for you know no it's good but you're
asking I'm thinking about it let mean
let's talk it through together so and if
I could maybe use force to try to change
what's going on with the child
internment camps bunch of annsofi people
get together what do they do next where
do they go what do they do I guess you
got me there I guess is well you know
outside you know the facilities and you
know just get burn it down maybe yeah I
don't think so and if you burn it down
won't you kill the kids inside yes of
course well I was just you don't want to
do that trying to take just the Marxist
approach to it you know I got you yeah I
think in this case you want to organize
I I'm with you the organizing and the
protesting but I don't think I'd go down
and burn down the facilities where the
kids are being held thank you for the
call appreciate it let's take a quick
break if you're on hold please don't
hang up because we're taking a bunch
more calls right after the break